okay we're good i can see the chat now
cool
uh let me know if i need to adjust the
levels at all as well
but yeah i've played probably about five
hours or so this game
five or six hours no one can see my
comments i can see your comments ygn
light
uh but yeah i'll just do some exploring
right now i'll be monitoring the chat as
i said before
but uh let's uh watch some dogs i guess
also for those wondering this is pc uh
with a with a 2080 ti
um i don't have it set for max well i
have most of it set for max but it's not
it's doing 1080p right now
today on the upload we're talking about
skye larson
the enigmatic founder granny i know this
character is
old but she's actually a spy no one
knows too much about
her and we only really see her these
days as a hologram
she was pretty young when she's cyber
delay i know i'm bummed cyberpunk at the
lake known for
introducing bagley to the world nowadays
it's hard to remember a world before
bagley bagley is the most advanced
significant ai
of our time and it's really i thought
the old folks couldn't run
this person's like not quite old and i
think that what's going on
i don't know middle age maybe but this
person's a spot so
i can actually but what do you know
about skylar
oh my car spawned over here
swimming look 60 not a granny yeah not
quite a granny
she is in heels though i think that's
what's more surprising is that she's
able to run in heels
like not even like a doesn't even look
like she's wearing heels she's just like
at a full sprint
how are you liking the game so far i
think of picking it up for pc might wait
for review embargoes yeah i don't know
how much i actually can say since the
review embargoes don't
technically lift until tomorrow i
believe
uh so yeah definitely check out those oh
here's my car
but like coming up today it is it is
pretty funny it is dark
she was pretty young when she launched
broken tech the company that is best
known
for introducing bagley to fight an old
lady
i can fight as an old lady i need to
recruit advanced significant ai
of our time and it's really blown away
ai
who's the map here's what we're looking
for oh i'll clear out an area that's
what i should do
what city of london
so like uh
can i not set waypoints i'm so close yet
because i'm so close
so like each area you can reclaim it for
dead sec by like completing
environmental missions more or less so
do one of those yeah i mean i can't
really imagine the options you buy
clothes i can't buy clothes
what do you know about skye i will do
that after this
mission thing pretty incredible um
yeah i actually kind of liked the
driving in this game uh it's leagues
ahead of
watch dogs one obviously and i don't
remember the driving
super well in the watch dogs too but it
feels pretty good to me it's very
arcadey
uh seems pretty responsive
that's where i gotta get in
usually yeah there it is disable that
wall easy
oh and then i've got this guy though
is this more realistic than gta i mean i
don't know
i probably not
but i guess it depends on what you're
what you're kind of like
quantifying is realistic i guess
like it seems like the mpc patterns are
probably more realistic than
you'd see in gta but like it seems more
arcady
go to the strip club i don't know if
there's a strip club
do a little bit of cloaking here not
gonna lie driving this the driving was
kind of bad and watch dogs too
uh well then i'd say this is probably
better uh
because i think the driving is pretty
fun i don't remember the driving in
watchdogs
too all that well but i didn't play a
whole lot of watch dogs too i played a
lot of one
and i think one i was just kind of like
burned
i care about this game more than
cyberpunk at this point at least they
don't
lie and keep keep up with the punk well
they did delay this game once it was
supposed to come out last year wasn't it
that was albion's automated propaganda
have you thrown a spanner into
ostensibly for broadcasting safety
notifications to nearby optics
really all it does is bombard them with
propaganda or rather it did
go to the hospital i probably can go to
the hospital i just don't know where it
is
come on get me out of here
one through ten so far at least i can't
i can't give it a score due to embargo
restrictions
and i'm check back tomorrow uh for
reviews
but i'm not allowed to say that
what platform this is pc
uh photograph evidence let's go
photograph some evidence
let's take a scooter i don't have time
for tracking uh yeah let's
show off my recruits here
so here's who i have recruited some of
these uh
i didn't actually recruit they were just
in the game as is i don't know if that's
the case for everyone but
this dude this lady this guy
this guy her she's the construction
worker i've got
uh a journalist professional hitman i'll
switch to him
at some point he does gunkata like uh
like john wick and whatnot
actually heck i'll switch to him now
cause he gambles so he's been spending
my money a lot
you play hit me yeah i'm gonna play
hitman right now i hope this isn't a bad
time but we need your particular skill
set for something
course i'm ready and i'm gonna take this
card that uh
was right next to me
coming up today on the upload we're
talking about skye
larson the enigmatic founder of broker
tech everyone knows her name but no one
knows
too much about her and we only really
see her these days as a hologram
she was pretty young i don't have john
wick
i know that like e3 i think or not
and i think that what sky larsen's done
with bagley is
absolutely incredible yeah i mean i
can't remember oops
apparently npcs remember what you've
done to them too
so i've probably pissed off a lot of
people
recruit aspire agent i was just playing
as a spy
what am i photographing hijack a news
drone photograph evidence in the album
of the corrupt schemes taking place
oh that's not what i wanted
is there a music player in the game
there there's a there's
um a radio
that you can listen to i don't know
if you can like in watch dogs too where
you had that music app i think if i
remember correctly
you could just pick music so i'm not
sure if there's something similar
um but there's like no phone in this
game that your characters have i mean
there's a phone that they pull out but
there's no like
interfacing with that phone
i don't know how to get down here where
they want me to be who would just leave
let's try a different one
photograph evidence i'm not sure what i
need to photograph
hack see toss up we'll do that
pigs
like for driving around and stuff the
founder of broker tech
everyone knows is this xbox no this is
uh this is pc
and we only really see her these days as
a hologram
she was pretty young when she launched
broker tech the company that
is best known for introducing
the world see this is why i'm gonna have
trouble recruiting people because i run
them over all the time
most advanced can you show us what
online is like i don't think i can
all the other ais that were created out
of i'm just gonna stick to
single players done with bagley is
absolutely incredible
yeah i mean i can't really imagine the
optic without it
but what do you know about sky larson
herself um
not a lot other than that she's actually
pretty incredible
um i've followed her work for a long
time and she's always been
a pretty private person
[Music]
all right i just want to get in here on
there in here somehow
what is the objective hacksie toss-up
um
uh i gotta go inside i wonder if i can
get inside from up here
i can't hijack that camera
go to gang hide out and show off the
combat yeah that's what i'm trying to do
let me try the other side maybe the
entrance is over this way
i've not played assassin's creed
valhalla yet but i know
we have done i'm being detected who
gives a [ __ ]
uh i know uh some people on our staff
have like previewed it at this point
i think we got a couple we do have a
couple of videos up because i edited one
of
impressions well i gotta put my gun away
wow that uh didn't work as i expected
all right i can just walk right in
does the movement in combat feel clunky
no it feels pretty good i know like
uh someone on staff who also was playing
it wasn't wild because
right trigger at least you're playing on
control is what's mapped to oh i need a
spider drone or something
uh is what's mapped to run so
to run you hold down r2 and the shoot
you hold
l2 and then r2
so i need a spider drone i think to get
through here
so i can hack that but i don't know
where there's a nearby spider drum
maybe this works i don't think this
works
can i even fit through here i can but i
can't hack it
because this thing is incapable of doing
so
uh which version would you recommend
standard or gold uh
i mean i don't know i guess it depends
maybe like wait for reviews and see if
it sounds like a game you're interested
in
uh i typically always just buy games at
the 60
like i don't like getting the gold and
whatnot and stuff like that
uh but part of that is just because
usually i have to move on from games
pretty quickly
and i usually don't have time to follow
up on season path stuff and whatnot
all right we're leaving that area
because i don't know how to fight i want
to fight
what we can do is we can try to
that guy doesn't like us let's try to
let's try to
get someone to join our dead sec here
all right chad if you guys see anyone
that stands out let me know
and we'll see if we can get them if
they've got the little thumbs down next
to their name and i highlight them
it means that they're not interested in
joining
uh dead sex yet but that doesn't mean i
can change their mind eventually
this looks like 30 frames per second
that's probably just the stream
all right i am being attacked
and this thing is slow as heck
i guess we couldn't handle that fall
[Music]
oh my god i'm being shocked
i should be playing the great tracing
oh god i can't drive trying to fiddle
with the radio
one thing i always forget is that
everything's reversed in london in terms
of cars like i drive on the wrong side
of the street try to get in on the wrong
[Music]
side
we are in pursuit
control i've lost the target
oh
here
control add suspect to the most wanted
list
over
all right let's try to recruit someone
drone summary uniform access already
have a construction worker so if i don't
need that
light step improves stealth ux designer
i'm playing on pc
bailout extra melee damage
oh a dart gun how about this person
so now that i've done that and just walk
you look up someone who's had just about
enough of this bollocks am i right
are you dead tech you got good timing
i need your help burning down everything
i ever done
whoa whoa what what i made drugs for a
living
legal like pharmaceuticals you know my
bell end of a boss stole my work sold it
to albion
and [ __ ] fired me what i hear is that
they're taking my bloody work
and running tests in some military lab i
don't want no part of that
if i get you the info can you get rid of
all that research
right right i'll set things in motion
yeah thanks
help her sister out and i'll owe you big
time
no i mean
bagley little help here please well i've
got nothing coming up but i know
something about ray tracing
let me make sure ray tracing is on
ray tracing is medium yeah it is on lab
but fortunately we've been given the
name of a high-level albion employee who
should have that information in their
personal files
here's their info
download the labs location all right
so i got to prove myself my driving
because someone was saying i drive
like a kid
i like the sound of the engine when you
go uh
under bridgestone whatnot
oh actually see that green dot that
green dot on my mini map
is a like a special recruit so i'm gonna
actually
pivot and we're gonna go for that
instead
[Music]
so
oh i can't make the jump perfect
all right
all right a philosopher let's try this
i didn't see shite you don't want me are
you mad
i don't know what you're on about you're
not with albion
oh thank christ oy chill mate
might be weak now take a deep breath
south bank and south
i was like doing some street art and i
absolutely love some albion pmcs doing
their dirty work
they had a group of protesters tied up
in a vacant building
and they were just beating them
senseless
[ __ ] you now there were cameras
everywhere no way my face wasn't
recorded
if albion decides they want to poke
around that footage i'm as good as dead
you'd need to get all the evidence
before they do i literally owe you my
life
right right i'll set things in motion
all right we're gonna switch to that
mission
i forgot who it was though hacker who's
a philosopher right
god i've got too many of these
philosophers there we go tracy o'hara
i've got a location from a gps and
there's a load of ctos surveillance
around
any number of cameras might have seen
her we need to dig into this
so apparently stuff i do npcs will track
and remember
so like if i go to
is it team no
yeah if i go to team view deep profile
it like shows what they do and
it's kind of interesting it's pretty
[Music]
cool
[Music]
we're good we're still on the road
oh i want this car no i want this i like
this car
let's stick
[Music]
oops
it's got to be up here right
what what oh was that follow i found the
old mission
um stupid
all right bear with me we're driving
[Music]
oops
foreign
we're turning off the music because i
don't know i keep forgetting but i gotta
remember to do it because i don't know
how
copyright is gonna work with these kind
of games
uh but the radio selection's been all
right i've actually mostly been
listening to the
little uh radio talk shows that they put
on because
that stuff's always my favorite in these
kind of games just because it like adds
so much to the world building
uh like that was always my favorite and
like the gta games and whatnot i drove
too far
drive on the sidewalk a little bit here
here's where our friend witnessed the
albion crime the security footage should
still be on site
right i'll get you that data
no yeah i do here gets the [ __ ] out of
here
[ __ ] dead
[ __ ] me talk about arms are dangerous
do anything
we're good oh
don't get brave on me
wait what was that [ __ ] useless
i think that's it it seems like it was
it
for the next one i'll do like extra like
gun play since that was the ctos hub
all right so i gotta get over there to
unlock it
oh where'd it go it's up here it's up
here
yeah so i have a skill that when i knock
out enemies they'll automatically
disappear
so i can hide them it's not a glitch
didn't mean to punch it but that works
[Music]
too
done sending you the cctv footage do you
see our target
yeah there she is clearly identifiable
too if albion saw this footage you'd be
pretty [ __ ]
[ __ ] however albion's crime was also
clearly recorded
which means we can turn this footage
back around on them we just have to wipe
the backup file from the central ctos
services
to protect the witnesses identity send
me the coordinates
didn't mean to do that
what problems have i had like glitch
wise uh it crashed once on me but other
than that it's been fine there's been
like
some visual bugs here and there but
so far seems like it's been running
pretty well i've only been playing on a
on pc
see look i keep getting in the wrong
side because
i'm not used to it
damn they really want us to go far huh
[Music]
what's my favorite thing about this game
i think i really like uh
how you can just recruit anyone you want
and how they have like patterns
and how their ai works uh it's just kind
of interesting like there's that story
about how like
[Music]
if you kill someone's wife in the game
then they'll go to the graveyard or
something like that
to mourn them which is dark but also i
find that
super interesting like i think a lot of
people especially in this chat right now
are very focused on the visuals but i
think a lot of the stuff under the hood
in this game is actually pretty
interesting um
not that you can't you know not not that
you can't like
be into the visuals or or annoyed about
the visuals
but like i don't know i think there's a
lot of interesting stuff going on under
the hood that
uh it isn't immediately apparent until
you've gotten your hands on it
or even until you've explored the game
[Music]
more
[Music]
oops
it's fine no one's the other room in
this area is heavily guarded by albion
goons
either they're protecting something or
it's bring a fascist to work though
[ __ ] that sounds bad we're probably not
the only ones after this evidence you'll
have to beat them to it
how deep is the character customization
well you can't create your character
you can recruit anyone but you can
customize their clothes
oh god did you see me
and then season two
follow me
wow
i also have permadeath mode on which i
think is pretty cool
oh move out of my way
let's go
there's the terminal we can do the
intrusion there this will trigger a
heavy security response
let's start armin traps now
oh they're above me all right
can we buy new clothes yeah i'll do that
next a lot of people are wondering about
clothes so we can head to the store
afterwards
if i survive
of
this
[Music]
[Music]
oh god oh no
i lost them so because i'm playing on
permadeath i just lost my hitman which
kind of sucks
but that's okay i should be able to
recruit another
we'll do
do the spy
it's not very batman with me dude yeah
sounds like things were going well
before the line cut exactly any news
operative kia
apologies
let's have some fun all right let's head
back up there
do they give you an option yeah you
don't have to play with permadeath mode
i just
decided to do it for some reason uh
i think cause everyone else was playing
regular and i wanted to
see what would it be like
down here all right
never okay to lose someone it's true
it's not
yeah you can do like permadeath easy if
you want
there's the door i guess i didn't really
need to do that
there's the terminal we can do the
intrusion there this will trigger a
heavy security response
i always have that equipped i don't want
that
all right let's try that again
ah
better get um
let's do this
all right someone just keeps yelling
prepare yourself better get ready
and it is getting annoying
i grab the evidence from the server and
scrub the local copy no way they'll
yeah but i want some exciting gameplay i
guess
what come on give me a take down
all right so i gotta get out of here now
i don't know the best way to do that
let's not lose another operative here
that's okay we've managed to get the
only copy of the footage you don't have
to worry about it anymore
thank christ i thought my days were
numbered i owe you
people like us with particular skills we
have a responsibility
you should join that sack fine
all right so that was it so now i got a
new character that i can play as
whenever i want
what difficulty is just normal so i can
hold x to swap
more badass folks like you should join
us i don't know why your clothes changed
yes well i'm ready to help however i can
excellent
all right so some people have been
saying they want to see
like clothing and whatnot so let's head
to a clothing store
so we can find one nearby
we're gonna play darts we can play darts
and drink too
oh come on where's the clothing store
there's usually just like areas with a
ton of them there we go
there's shops
what am i doing what am i driving oh i'm
not the spy anymore i can't
get the cool spy car all right yeah
we're back in this thing
and drink hello matt we'll do that let
me go to the store first
and then
after i you know run some people over
and whatnot
is
oh here's one right here
so yeah you can buy
jackets all sorts of stuff i don't know
if i want to spend money on this
character i don't particularly like this
character
uh oh sorry i didn't mean to quit though
uh but there's also the wardrobe so any
store you can access your wardrobe you
can pick your mask there's a pig mask
everyone likes
we'll equip the pig mask
uh i don't have any face work but
there's
leg wear
hand wear
none of the clothes i have really fit
this lady
uh this is with like a regular xbox one
looking controller
but it's on pc
all right darts and drink
where the darts at
there we go close by perfect
uh when you buy clothing you get it for
everyone i haven't tried like i don't
know if you equip clothing on one person
then it disappears on the other person
that you have equipped
uh but i'm pretty sure if you just buy
it any operator can wear those clothes
so if you want you could like
have a uniform for all your operators uh
so you could just like
make them all wear the same stuff
there's darts here it says too yeah it
starts here cool
okay oh no don't punch
so you can play as everyone pretty much
uh they're like certain characters that
don't want to
work with uh deadset
uh and you have to do things to convince
them otherwise i think if you just like
take back the area then that usually
convinces them but it seems like you can
like
irreparably piss them off
just shut up and play come on
trying to talk to people they got
questions
i'm here to offer advice batman's
superman obviously that's a lie you're a
drunken tit
driving looks man i like the driving
i guess to each their own i'd love you
all right
we're proper wasted as the brits would
say
i think now we'll play some darts
oh this is gonna be fun i can already
tell
so basically i just need to like pull
the trigger on it
and can i get it
[Music]
if you change the hair no you just have
to get a different operator
or a different recruit i guess
uh ray tracing is set to medium
and i can't hit this
[Music]
there we go all right
[Music]
we aren't doing too well there we go
got one 40 left if i hit this i think i
can win
it did not last shot must be a double
it's got to be a 10 all right
miss is there an airport i don't think
so
oh no
that looked good that looked good i
guess not though
here we go now my best performance
uh i'm using a 2080ti
all right let's switch characters shall
we let's get a character that's not
drunk here
so also like different operators have
different uniforms depending on what
they are
um so like this character in particular
can sneak into construction areas
because she's a construction worker
i can change into it if i go up but i
don't want to
do it right now because i don't really
need to what you can also do is you can
call a cargo drone on command
so i can just like
call it hop on this thing
and just take off
i can't go super high though which is
kind of disappointing because like i
want to get on some of these buildings
um but it doesn't seem like i can go
that high
oh but this is something let's do this
this wall's a bit drab isn't it
won't turn any art grants but i think it
does the job oh the drunk character
continued
stumble
now there's a statement the whole bar of
southwark will see this and though
someone is sticking it to albion
i like the direction you took with this
one thank you sweetie
since it's night i wish it was raining
too like we could show off some of the
ray tracing when it's night raining and
like some of the more
neon lit areas but it looks like it's
not raining i can still try to get to
some of these more neon lit areas
what i remember
uh
let's go to the city of london
did i not i did where is it
on the map though why is it not showing
up
i think it's this way yeah there it is
i think ubisoft did a good job in
portraying london says random unknown
i'm actually
yeah i mean i'm curious to see what
because we've got a couple people from
london in the office and i'm curious to
see what they think because i remember
playing
uh watch dogs 2 and having like lived in
the bay area
i didn't think it really nailed the bay
area at least as well as i hoped
um but i i'd be curious to see what
londoners think of this
go underground oh yeah we can go to a
fight club maybe that's what we should
do
let me see if we can find one here
i don't know what these symbols are
oh man is there there's like no legend
from what i can tell
you can play some we can do some kick up
which is basically just kick a soccer
ball around it's like a little mini game
oh there's a fight club here we go bare
knuckle brawl
but i'm gonna get off this thing because
it is pretty slow
it may have height but it does not have
speed
actually i didn't want to do that let's
come back to me
or not i just wanted to stop it
oh this thing's fast what
okay
uh this is a pc watching for suspect
control i've lost the target
on to follow i'm not going to drive now
i got to take over because i don't want
to get wanted after i'm not wanted i
will uh turn on auto drive
oops
[Music]
all right just a nail gun to the face
now we're gonna hide
control i'm ready to immobilize the
target
we'll hide and then we'll do the the
bare knuckle brawl
move on control we're returning to hq
oh no oh my god
you did you just ran me over oh no
well i messed up
when you're bad at hiding i guess i am i
mean it worked the first time i just
jumped on his car and apparently if you
jump on their car they don't like that
control we are unsighted of
somewhere else but suspect good we're
good
terminating the search ctrl
looking for some action eh
[Applause]
straight
[Applause]
[Music]
solid strike from
i'll be gentle baby
i don't think there's an airport airport
in the game if there is i haven't found
it
[Music]
they're ready
yeah the fighting in this game feels
pretty good
it's like not super deep all it is is so
like
b to dodge if you get a perfect dodge
you can get a counter x is to hit
and why is to do a guard break
[Music]
so like when it oh solid
[Music]
when it slows down a bit it means i do a
perfect dodge
plays a paramedic because they have to
figure out yeah i can do that i have a
paramedic
[Music]
and we're ready
doing money yeah you get money for
fighting
[Applause]
oh
oh yeah doesn't seem fair
[Applause]
uh if i beat them i can recruit them
so if i finish all this the little menu
should pop up and it'll be like here's
the characters you can now recruit
let's make this interesting just like a
proper live highlight oh it's bad
not that it will help
[Music]
i oh see that one
if they wake up
oh
it is i got a little bit of money
[Applause]
[Music]
so yeah so now i can like save all these
people to my recruits and try to get
them
so we'll do these two because they're
kind of interesting i guess
tell me all right i'm gonna switch to
my paramedic here
which is a criminal event
neutralize vip let's do this one
[Music]
time
[Music]
play on the street so you can make money
i can play on the street i don't know if
i make money
[Music]
i'll play i'll play a bit when i get to
the objective or i get to the
location i'm marked
oh
there we go there's some music we can
just sit here listen to the music
if you're playing as a paramedic do you
go on paramedic type missions
i don't think so
i think it's just like what your
background and just kind of what
the character's background and just kind
of depends what uh
stuff they're equipped with
oh come on i thought i could climb up
pipes it's not
i guess just not that pipe
oh they do give you money
will this hold me over until cyberpunk
releases uh
i don't know i guess it depends
i would just wait for review see if it's
your kind of thing
and if it is
orders are maybe to arrest
um what is that a dude
that is a dude all right take him out
next
there we go
not sure where the vip is probably in
the building if i can go in it
oh
get ready
you're in trouble now
he's got grenades i guess
all right
oh jump jump over that
[Music]
yeah in case cyberpunk got delayed again
by three weeks
it's now coming out december 10th
i don't have a lot of operators with
guns here
which is worrying oh this guy's got a
a gun what is this
take cover do it stealth yeah i probably
should have
but i blew my cover trying to get that
guy because he turned around
last minute why'd it go dead but i think
i did it operative kia
apologies seems that manky little nerd
was the one who kept diverting relief
supplies away from the borough to keep
everyone in line for albion
these days you can do a lot more evil
with a spread
heat than a drone fleet [ __ ] great
we have 20. i don't know what kind of
drone this is let's say
riot drone
right drone hack god dang i need five
more to be able to hack that thing
all right now i can that's nice
oh i didn't even need to go back in here
here i am
stuck in here
did anybody order a ps5 in here i
managed to get one
uh not early i just i pre-ordered one
that should arrive shortly after launch
hopefully
i have my doubts but we'll see
oh that's not good oh no we're fine this
guy's tough
easy
right
all right so we're gonna go for about 20
more minutes or so is there anything
people in the chat want to see
i don't like this operative's closing i
can switch to a different one i just
switched him because he had a gun
uh we'll be
this hacker guy i guess
dead set calling you ready i'm born
ready
why what one
no no no i know why
oh [ __ ] off
uh go to london bridge all right we'll
go to london bridge
although this is where everyone in chat
finds out that i don't really know
anything about london
so i don't know which one's the london
bridge
is it this one this looks like yeah
that's the london tower bridge
london bridge that says london bridge
is this playable now no it comes out
friday i think
a couple days from now
free fall off big ben i would do that
except uh
i have permadeath mode on so i just lose
an operator for good
but i guess if you really want to see it
we can uh
we can we can do that with one of the
characters i don't care much about
it
got it watch for hostiles people
you're brilliant
[Music]
crash some cars
yeah that's not the london bridge can
anyone see the suspect
that's what the map said
the millennium bridge
golden jubilee bridge westminster bridge
waterloo bridge
tower bridge can you crash some cars
go to hackney okay we'll go
we'll go to hack me and crash some cars
call 999 this is serious
control we are still on the suspect
good lord oh my god
[Music]
suspect has cleared the checkpoints
the suspect
to a storm
suspect left the vehicle maintaining
visuals
well there's a smashed up vehicle for
you guys
listening mode must have skipped counter
surveillance today in fascist schools
they might recorded something about our
prospect cool let's get some data
oh be careful
let's see download the audio records all
right we'll do this quickly
oh actually let's play some soccer first
or some football
basically i just need to like hit the
button prompts
in that little circle you got this keep
up
oh shoot i wasn't ready i was itching my
nose
let's go
too late oh [ __ ] this [ __ ]
all right wrong button
so let's infiltrate this place
it's called football i know
watch dogs every year i don't know it's
been a couple years since two when did
that come out 2016.
that's here
now
yes yes well done now get out of there
so we can take a look at what you've got
slowly lower myself away easy
easy almost clean not quite
[Music]
oh these things
just as i thought take a listen to this
you find the drugs cash
it was right where you said aren't we
lucky told you not to worry we've got
that asset over a barrel the goods will
always be where they need to be
that's a piss-poor attempted coded
language isn't it it seems i was wrong
the man we're after isn't being hunted
by albion he's planting evidence for
them
we also have a word with him stop a meet
and greet bagley yeah
all right we uh got some boat gameplay
too
some of that hot boat gameplay
oh [ __ ] oh no i stuck
but it's about all we have time for
unfortunately
but we do have some watchdogs videos you
can check out now including one about
recruiting
and some gameplay uh and make sure to
check back soon for the reviews as well
uh for our review as well uh and with
that thank you all so much for stopping
by thank you for your questions
and we will see you next time
you